uh we were teammates when you when you
got caught with the burner account
one thing i love about the burner
account is
everything that you said on the burner
account you just started to say on kevin
durant's account yeah a lot of people
don't like it as you know most people
voice they don't like how you
respond to some fans or how you respond
to this how you always tweeting what do
you make of people's reaction to you
responding to fans and if you think
something you send it yeah i just think
people are still upset that i went to
the warriors and a lot of people who are
cavs fans who
enjoy watching the cavs beach all before
which is a lot of people i didn't
realize that i got
a lot of people enjoyed seeing y'all
lose in 2016.
and a lot of those people were upset
that we were so good and they're still
upset
because you do the same [ __ ] on twitter
damian lillard does the same [ __ ] on
twitter cj mccullum does the same [ __ ]
on twitter we all do the same [ __ ]